je ne peux pas accepter que cette
situation se produise en restant les
bras croisés et en regardant la
catastrophe advenir
[Musique]
bonjour
il est midi deux femmes s'arrêtent
devant ses tournesols devant Gogh estimé
à 85 millions d'euros
et les asperges de soupe à la tomate
devant un public Méduse
[Musique]
puis ces militantes écologistes se
collent les mains au mur
qu'est-ce qui a le plus de valeur l'art
ou la vie êtes-vous plus préoccupé par
la protection d'une peinture ou la
protection de notre planète
c'est une séquence qui a beaucoup fait
réagir et on peut se poser plein de
questions par rapport à cette séquence
la première c'est qu'est-ce qui conduit
des jeunes gens à des extrémités
pareilles combien d'années il a fallu de
de déni à regarder ailleurs d'une
certaine manière pour qu'ils en viennent
à faire ça la deuxième chose que je me
dis moi c'est que c'est quand même une
sacrée performance d'art contemporain
parce que l'art contemporain qu'est-ce
que c'est finalement c'est une
performance qui va faire réfléchir qui
va poser des questions qui va créer des
conversations là on peut se dire qu'ils
ont vraiment réussi leur coup
ce qui est très intéressant c'est que ça
a créé une sorte de déluge d'insultes et
hystérique alors que finalement ils ont
envoyé de la sauce tomate sur une vitre
c'est-à-dire qu'ils n'ont même pas
endommagé le tableau et puis on peut se
dire pourquoi est-ce que ça fait plus
parler qu'on s'attaque d'une certaine
manière même si c'est seulement à une
vitre à une représentation de la nature
plutôt que de la destruction de la
nature elle-même c'est-à-dire que on
voit des rapports du GIEC qui sortent ou
des rapports de l'IPBES qui est le
l'équivalent du GIC pour la biodiversité
qui nous explique que cette planète
pourrait devenir inhabitable qui a un
million d'espèces qui sont en danger
qu'on a perdu 70% des populations de
vertébrés depuis les années 70 que le
climat se réchauffe au point qu'on va
vivre des sécheresses des catastrophes
climatiques
on en parle un peu et tout d'un coup on
envoie de la sauce tomate sur une oeuvre
d'art et là on se dit ça c'est sacré
donc d'une certaine manière on considère
que la représentation de la nature par
des êtres humains par des artistes et
plus sacrés que la nature elle-même à
laquelle nous devons la vie et pour
toutes ces raisons là je pense qu'ils
ont vraiment vraiment bien fait de
lancer cette action finalement qu'est-ce
qui est violent est-ce que c'est de
saboter un pipeline ou est-ce que c'est
de construire un pipeline sachant
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple quand total
va construire cette immense pipeline en
Ouganda qui va déverser des millions de
tonnes de CO2 dans l'atmosphère ça va
avoir des conséquences dramatiques sur
le climat mais donc ça va avoir des
conséquences dramatiques sur des gens
c'est-à-dire que des gens vont mourir
des conséquences du changement
climatique des gens vont devoir migrer
des gens vont manquer d'eau mais moi je
crois que ça c'est infiniment plus
violent que des militants qui vont
essayer d'empêcher que ce tuyau soit
construit ou qui vont essayer de le
sabot er une fois qu'il l'est
[Musique]
et moi je me suis rendu compte que quand
on montre uniquement les choses qui vont
mal ça déclenche des réflexes de peur de
déni de fuite et qu'on a besoin d'avoir
un horizon vers lequel aller un projet
de société et de montrer les solutions
puisqu'on connaît presque tous les
solutions à tous nos problèmes et on
voulait faire un film qui soit vraiment
grand public qui soit un vrai film de
cinéma qui raconte une histoire et en
même temps ou quand on connaît rien à
tous ces sujets là on puisse apprendre
des tas de choses ce qui m'est beaucoup
apparu pendant toutes ces années où
j'étais militant écologiste c'est que
simplement d'écrire la catastrophe ça ça
crée une sorte d'effet de sidération les
gens sont écrasés par l'ampleur du
problème et par le sentiment d'être tout
petit donc montrer des gens qui sont
dans une démarche créative et dans une
démarche constructive ça réveille
quelque chose en nous qui peut avoir
envie d'aller dans le même sens bon en
l'occurrence
ça a mis quand même beaucoup plus de
temps que ce que j'imaginais parce que
ça a commencé très très doucement et ça
a fini par marcher mais le film a fait
un million quasiment 200 000 entrées en
40 semaines c'est à dire que ça a été
très très progressif ça a été vraiment
du bouche à oreille
[Musique]
le référendum
c'est une décision qui est à Mama donc
je peux tout à fait la mettre au
référendum mettre une décision une
proposition que vous allez faire au
référendum maintenant il faut que
je vous en donne le cadre et qu'il faut
qu'on voit ensemble précisément ce que
ça veut dire à la sortie de la réunion
les membres de la Convention étaient
partagés
on discours a été correct je trouve
après qu'est-ce qui va en faire je sais
pas on verra à la fin je pense que là la
motivation
ils pourront pas tout mettre à la
poubelle c'est pas possible sinon ça
veut dire que
la convention c'était bidon quoi
est-ce que c'est évident c'est ça ma
question quand j'ai été rencontré
Emmanuel Macron au mois de mois de
février
2019 je crois avec Marion Cotillard
la conversation qu'on a eu c'est je sais
et vous savez que les mesures qu'il
faudrait prendre pour résoudre la crise
climatique vous ne les prendrez pas
d'une part parce que ça va à l'encontre
d'un certain nombre d'intérêts
économiques qui vous ont porté au
pouvoir de l'autre parce que certaines
de ces décisions sont très impopulaires
et que vous avez envie d'être élu donc
vous vous prendrez pas ce risque
et puis parce que
malheureusement vous vivez encore dans
un logiciel qui est celui du 20e siècle
je pense que la seule solution c'est de
remettre en fait le problème à la
population française c'est comme si
allégoriquement on se mettait tous
autour d'une table on se donnait tous le
moyen de faire un constat commun de se
mettre d'accord ok qu'est-ce qui se
passe et ce qu'on est d'accord sur ce
qui se passe et une fois qu'on est
d'accord sur ce qui se passe qu'est-ce
qu'on est prêt à mettre en oeuvre comme
solution donc je dis le faire pour 60
millions de personnes c'est un petit peu
compliqué en revanche on peut créer une
assemblée de personnes tirées au sort
qui sont représentatives de toutes les
réalités de la France et on peut les
faire travailler comme ça c'est alors
faire faire un constat commun les faire
rencontrer des scientifiques rencontrer
les experts rencontrer des gens qui sont
représentatifs de tous les secteurs
d'activité et à partir de là leur donner
une mission qui est d'élaborer un plan
pour que la France tienne ses objectifs
climatiques donc ce qu'on peut
reconnaître au gouvernement c'est que
ils nous ont laissé faire ils nous ont
donné les moyens de le faire c'est quand
même investi 5 millions d'euros pour
qu'on puisse le faire
ils ne sont pas intervenus pendant le
processus c'est-à-dire que tous ces
faits de façon vraiment très très neutre
à l'issue de ce processus c'est 150
personnes tirées au sort dont certaines
étaient climato-sceptiques avant de
venir ne connaissez pas les sujets sans
fichier et perduement d'autres le
connaissaient hyper bien était passionné
d'autres travaillaient dans des secteurs
d'activité il y en avait pilote d'avion
et les gens qui faisaient le transport
routiers ils ont produit
un rapport avec 149 propositions qui
vont plus loin que ce que tous les
gouvernements ont fait ces 30 dernières
années
grâce à ce principe de délibération
ce qui veut quand même dire que ce que
les responsables politiques nous disent
à longueur de temps qui est on ne va pas
prendre cette mesure parce que les
Français ne sont pas prêts c'est faux
les Français ne sont pas prêts à ce
qu'on leur impose des mesures de force
en revanche ils sont prêts à participer
à les élaborer si on leur en donne le
pouvoir et si on leur donne le cadre
pour pouvoir le faire ensuite le
président de la République n'a pas tenu
sa parole c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas
fait comme il avait dit passer les
mesures de la convention citoyenne sans
filtre au Parlement ou au référendum il
a laissé là encore de grandes
entreprises multinationales des tricoter
ces mesures parfois même ce sont les
ministères qui l'ont fait ou la haute
administration qui l'a fait de peur que
les entreprises
et donc ça a donné une loi climat qui
est une loi assez faible où il y a à
peine 20% des propositions de la
convention citoyenne qui ont été reprise
je suis absolument ravi qu'on ait réussi
à le faire et j'en vois tous les jours
les conséquences positives
et à la fois ça m'a permis de mesurer à
nouveau à quel point
la politique est gangrené encore une
fois par le par l'influence des
entreprises multinationales et à quel
point la parole publique est dégradée
dire que Emmanuel Macron n'a pas tenu sa
parole il s'est dédié et ça c'est très
grave c'est très grave et ça continue à
faire monter une forme de populisme ça
continue à encourager les gens à ne pas
aller voter parce qu'ils se disent de
toute façon ça sert à rien parce qu'il
nous manque
aux Inde le match de la non-violence a
remporté la plus belle victoire de sa
vie par un jeune de plus de 5 jours il
vient d'arrêter le glissement de
l’indoustan et du Pakistan vers une
guerre qui aurait plongé dans le chaos
une masse de 400 millions d'hommes la
volonté de jeûner à mort de Gandhi a
arrêté l'Inde sur la pente fatale
miracle où s'affirme qu'il y a encore
une place pour l'esprit
[Musique]
là encore c'est intéressant cette
archive parce que il y a Gandhi et le
mythe de Gandhi
quand on dit a remporté cette bataille
sur plusieurs fronts et pas tout seul
tout comme Martin Luther King c'est que
pendant que Gandhi menait ses actions
non violentes il y avait tout un tas de
d'Indiens qui menait des actions
directes qui sabotaient des lignes de
train qui mettaient des bâtons dans les
roues autant qu'il le pouvait à l'Empire
britannique et il y avait un récit
différent qui est qui commençait à
s'élaborer qui était que les Indiens
valaient autant que les Anglais donc ça
ça n'était pas des citoyens de seconde
zone et qu'ils étaient absolument
capables de se gérer tout seul et qui
avait absolument pas besoin de l'Empire
britannique pour le faire et puis là
encore il y a eu une circonstance
historique quand est-ce que
l'indépendance de l'Inde est intervenue
à la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale à
un moment où il y a eu une
long mouvement de décolonisation et où
l'empire britannique était exemples
financièrement militairement toutes ces
circonstances là ont joué c'est pas
simplement Gandhi qui est allé marcher
et qui a jeûné même si ça a eu un impact
considérable mais là encore on voit bien
que la la force du récit est importante
c'est ce que Gandhi a réussi de façon
magistrale c'est raconter une histoire
qui qui était simple à comprendre et qui
s'est propagé dans le monde entier et
qui existe toujours aujourd'hui et il se
trouve que Gandhi dans sa vie de tous
les jours n'était pas aussi non violent
que on voudrait bien le croire même dans
sa relation aux femmes par exemple
[Musique]
la pauvreté à mon avis actuellement est
une valeur de bien-être tant qu'on ne
considéra comme la pauvreté comme comme
quelque chose de similaire à la misère
on ne comprendra pas que la pauvreté
c'est le rapport que je puis avoir avec
ce qui m'est nécessaire sans outre
passer mes besoins pour garder la
maîtrise de ce que je suis et de ce que
je dois gérer la pauvreté justement ça
n'est pas la misère et c'est vrai que
Pierre a eu cette
espèce d'intuition qu'il fallait
retourner vers une forme de sobriété et
que et que nos civilisations avaient
besoin de ça et que c'était sans doute
la grande direction dans laquelle
l'humanité avait besoin de se s'orienter
alors évidemment
pas les gens qui sont dans une dans une
misère crasse ceux qui ont déjà beaucoup
plus que ce dont ils ont besoin et puis
nos civilisations de façon générale qui
qui consomment des quantités
considérables de matière et d'énergie
c'est dur de vivre la sobriété heureuse
dans ce monde là justement dans ce monde
dans lequel on est
bombardé de messages publicitaire toute
la journée dans lequel on est soumis à
des modes une espèce d'injonction à
consommer en permanence donc
je pense que plus ça va plus je vieillis
et
plus je commence à y aller
[Musique]
pour la première fois ce matin il y a
ces arafates quitte son quartier général
de Ramallah
ce sont ses premiers pas d'homme libres
après près de 5 mois de siège par
l'armée israélienne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peut-être que ça va être le petit
ingrédient qui pourrait permettre au
processus de paix d'aller plus loin donc
en 203 on a organisé un premier congrès
on a rassemblé près de 400
religieux juifs et musulmans les plus
grands religieux juifs musulmans du
monde et on les a mis dans un hôtel
pendant quatre jours et on a essayé de
voir ce qui se passait donc ce qui était
quand même une expérience assez
ahurissante et eux-mêmes étaient
ahuristes quand il se regardait les uns
les autres ils avaient du mal à croire
qu'ils étaient dans la même pièce et
donc en entre les deux congrès
donc on en a fait un premier à Bruxelles
on en a fait un second assez vie puisque
Séville est une sorte de haut lieu de
de la vie en commun des juifs et des
musulmans on a voulu faire sortir des
imams de Gaza pour la première fois de
l'envie et pour ça on a été rencontré il
y a certains Arafat pour qu'il leur
donne l'autorisation de le faire et on
s'est retrouvé à la moukata à Ramallah
donc dans ce quartier général qui à
moitié détruit et qui laissait détruit
d'ailleurs pour les caméras c'est à dire
qu'ils laissaient la moitié du bâtiment
effondré pour que quand les médias
viennent y voir
ils puissent voir les stigmates de des
attaques israéliennes il y avait des des
piles de voitures complètement
concassées écrabouillé les unes sur les
autres on rentrait dans une espèce de
méchant couloir avec des néons et on se
retrouve dans une pièce à attendre sur
des vieilles chaises et donc là je me
souviens du chef de protocole d'Arafat
qui nous montrait trois types en train
de regarder la télé sur un vieux matelas
ressort en nous disant donc lui c'est le
ministre de l'Intérieur lui c'est le
ministre de l'Éducation et donc moi
j'avais 25 ans je regardais ça je
faisais qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire et Arafat nous a reçu après
l'oeil mouillé en nous prenant dans ses
bras donc une espèce de de sentiment un
peu étrange de se dire
qu'est-ce que je suis en train de faire
qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce que ce
type est un chef de guerre est-ce que
c'est un terroriste est-ce que c'est au
contraire quelqu'un qui veut la paix et
qui a un héros pour son peuple et donc
tous ces sentiments mêlés et pendant une
demi-heure
il nous a raconté des histoires
c'est-à-dire que nous on venait négocier
et lui nous racontait des histoires et
puis à la fin il a fini par accepter que
les imams Palestiniens viennent et on a
pu organiser ce deuxième congrès j'ai
pas cru pouvoir faire la paix au
Moyen-Orient mais
ça m'intéressait ça m'intéressait de
faire quelque chose qui qui pourrait
avoir un impact sur le monde moi
j'entendais parler du conflit Israël au
palestinien depuis que j'étais tout
petit je sortais d'une une petite
déception de d'une carrière de comédien
où je trouvais pas tout le sens que
j'aurais voulu mettre dans dans mon
métier et je me suis dit allez ça va
être l'aventure ça va être l'aventure et
puis ça se trouve ça peut être utile
d'une façon ou d'une autre
[Musique]
mon enfant
pas ça révérend
[Musique]
en main de bataille
l'hiver j'étais au ventes
de la grande maison
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui avait
jeté le
parmi les gens
[Musique]
j'ai raconté plusieurs fois que j'aimais
pas beaucoup l'enfance
j'aimais pas beaucoup d'enfance parce
que
[Musique]
parce que ça aussi je l'ai déjà raconté
j'ai subi un viol quand j'avais 6 ans
et
ça et je m'en suis pas souvenu après
parce que j'ai fait comme comme beaucoup
de d'enfants ou parfois d'adultes
d'ailleurs qui vivent des situations
traumatiques comme celle-là j'ai fait
une une dissociation c'est complètement
oublié pendant des années
mais j'avais le sentiment que l'enfant
c'était un endroit de
de soumission que j'avais pas de pouvoir
sur le monde j'avais pas de pouvoir sur
le monde qui m'entourait que j'avais pas
de pouvoir sur mon destin et je pense
que c'était renforcé par cette
expérience là tout ça n'est pas étranger
sur le fait que j'essaie d'avoir une
prise sur le monde aujourd'hui
mais après en parler publiquement moi
j'ai décidé de le faire parce que il y
avait eu un
toute la vague mis tout puis mis tout
l'inceste et que
qui m'a semblé que c'était important que
il y ait des hommes aussi qui parlent et
qui
et qui explique que
les agressions sexuelles les viols ça
pouvait aussi arriver aux hommes mais
c'est surtout aux enfants
et que le patriarcat la domination
masculine
et les agressions sexuelles de toutes
sortes il faut en sortir et c'est
souvent les femmes qui le disent et donc
ça crée une espèce de trucs entre les
hommes et les femmes alors que il y a
des hommes qui sont victimes de ça donc
je pense que c'est important que les
hommes prennent la parole sur ce sujet
là aussi et qu'on soit des alliés
[Musique]
je reviens à moi parce que j'ai basculé
au moment où j'ai eu cette dépression
nerveuse et j'ai déjà cette cure de
sommeil où je suis arrivé à l'hôpital le
par exemple je suis arrivé le 14 juin et
j'arrive à foller là-dedans
des pilules vous allez voir tout va bien
se passer vous allez vous réveiller
demain matin pleine forme et tout et
puis le lendemain matin alors que
j'étais rentré par exemple le 14 juin je
me suis je suis allé dans
dans le bureau de l'infirmier et c'était
le 15 septembre
première impression comme quoi on est
très égocentrique dans ces cas-là j'ai
dit quoi le monde à côté de la tournée
pendant que moi j'existais plus
et il s'est passé des choses il y a des
gens qui vont dormir fait l'amour manger
ça continuait j'ai là on se rend compte
qu'on se prend vraiment pour le centre
du monde oui bah ça me parle évidemment
moi j'ai fait un gros burn out en 2012
parce que j'ai été dans une espèce de
syndrome de chevalier blanc et de
militantisme sacrificiel et
avec l'idée qu'il fallait sauver le
monde je pensais pas que j'allais le
sauver à moi tout seul avec l'idée qu'il
fallait sauver le monde mais sauf que on
sauve pas le monde avec ses petits brins
que c'est une tâche qui n'a pas de faim
donc j'ai on peut travailler 90 heures
par semaine et puis tout va toujours mal
et puis voilà et puis je me suis
effondré et ça m'a permis de comprendre
plusieurs choses ça m'a permis de
comprendre d'abord que
j'essayais de me réparer moi-même en
réparant le monde et que ça marchait pas
très bien qui valait mieux que j'essaie
de regarder ce qui n'allait pas
et puis que
j'étais pas au bon endroit
qu'en fait j'avais besoin de j'ai besoin
de créer profondément et que là j'étais
en train de faire de la gestion donc du
coup j'ai démissionné de
j'ai quitté deux Cdi
et je me suis dit il faut que je me
remette à créer donc j'ai c'est à ce
moment-là que j'ai publié un recueil de
poèmes là qui s'appelle assis sur le fil
et puis que j'ai décidé de faire demain
sans savoir si ça allait marcher en
empruntant des sous et
heureusement que ça a marché parce que
sinon j'aurais été un peu à poil
[Musique]
je vais choisir Bernard Pivot
est-ce que votre sensibilité qui est
très aiguë très pointue avait un peu
pressenti ce succès
[Rires]
un peu
quand on a fait demain en fait on était
en salle de montage
donc on n'avait pas terminé le film et
j'ai dit à Mélanie et à Sandy qui est la
menteuse avec laquelle je travaille je
pense qu'on va avoir un César
ils m'ont dit
ta gueule fini déjà le film et puis on
verra plus tard là par exemple vous
mettez une photo du Festival de Cannes
quand j'étais jeune comédien et que je
faisais mes études dramatiques au cours
périmonie j'aurais jamais pensé qu'un
jour
j'étais au Festival de Cannes devant je
sais pas une centaine de photographes
j'aurais jamais pensé ça il y a plein de
moments de ma de ma vie où je me pince
un peu où je me demande ce qu'il est ce
qui s'est passé pour en arriver là mais
c'est bien je me dis que je me suis pas
rendu en tout cas
[Musique]